[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
السوريون من نكبه الانقاض الى نكبات
المساعدات وشمال البلاد منسي وبات ضحيه
المناكفات السياسيه
من تواعد اوروبا بالزوال الى تحديزنسكي
صقور روسيا يتصدرون مشهد الحرب في
اوكرانيا
في ارتباط الاجسام الطائره ببرنامج تجسس
تابع للصين او لدوله اخرى
العربيه اول وسيله اعلاميه تصل الى جبل
كودو وترافق القوات العراقيه على الحدود
مع ايران وتركيا في جوله حصريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى تفاصيل اخبار الساعه المناطق
المتضرره في سوريا تئن في صمت تاخر في
اصول المساعدات وبطء في عمليه انتشار
الضحايا ووضع صحي مقلق في ظل تخوف من
انتشار الاوبئه كلها عوامل تجعل الوضع
مزريا في المناطق السوريه المتضرره من
الزلزال منظمه الصحه العالميه دقت ناقوس
الخطر حيث اعربت عن قلقها بشان وضع السكان
في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا وتحديدا تلك التي
تسيطر عليها فصائل المعارضه والتي تعاني
شحا في تدفق المساعدات
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا زاد الاحوال سوءا
فالوضع كان متهالكا اساسا بسبب الحرب
المتواصله في البلاد منذ اكثر من عشر
سنوات البنيه التحتيه وشبكات المياه
والكهرباء والصرف الصحي باتت مدمره بشكل
كامل وهو ما ينذر بوضع صحي صعب للغايه
بهذا الخصوص افدت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيوسف ان من بين الاولويات
الفوريه هي توفير امكانيه الحصول على مياه
صالحه للشرب وخدمات صرف صحي لمنع انتشار
الامراض على غرار الكوليرا التي تسجل
انتشارا منذ اشهر في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل غارقين في الازمه وبالطبع الزلزال
يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه الوضع الصحي تحت
الضغط ايضا نقص الوقود والتضخم والازمه
الاقتصاديه وتاثر النظام الصحي بشده جراء
وباء كوفيد 19 كلها اشياء تجعل الامر اكثر
صعوبه
اذا مشاهدينا هذا الان خبر عاجل اعلام
اللبنانيه تحدث عن هزه ارضيه شعره بها
سكان عدد من المناطق في البلاد قبل ذلك
دمشق كانت كذلك اعلنت عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه
بعد قليل سنتابع مع مراسلنا من سوريا بعد
قليل اذا اما على صعيد الوضع الانساني
الزلزال رش الملحه على جروح السوريين
الذين عاقبتهم السياسه والطبيعه بل حتى
الجغرافيا كانت قاسيه على من ذهبوا الى
الجنوب الشمالي لتركيا فعاشوا ويلات
الزلزال ليعود بعضهم ادراجه اما ميتا او
منكوبا فمئنه السوريين الذين يقطنون
الاراضي التركيه وتضرروا من الزلزال
المدمر بداوا في العبور الى الاراضي
السوريه وذلك بحثا عن مكان للمبيت او دعما
لاهاليهم بعد الفاجحه
المعابر للحدوديه التي فتحت كانت شهده
ايضا على عوده بطعم الموت للمئه من
السوريين فقد دخلت العديد من الشاحنات
الاراضي السوريه محمله بجثامين من قضوا في
الزلزال في تركيا العديد من العائلات
السوريه فضلت نقل جثث ذويها الى الداخل
السوري وخاصه ممن تعود اصولهم الى ادلب
وريف حلب او ممن لهم اقارب في باقي
المحافظات السوريه
[موسيقى]
ماساه الزلزال في سوريا لم تخلو من سجالات
واتهامات بين القوى السياسيه بشان تجاهل
مناطق عديده دمرها الزلزال وقتل وجرح فيها
المئات من سكانها انا فاقد
[موسيقى]
وفي كذا ولد كمان يعني مين مجموعه حوالي
25 شخص
هي بتهتز الدنيا
تنزل بنايه مثل طابق البسكوت
وبنته وبنته وراحوا
قصص نقلها المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عن
الاهالي هناك وقال ناشطون فيها ان ما خلفه
الزلزال من دمار لم يكن في الحسبان
فقد طال الزلزال احدى وعشرين قريه على طول
خط كامل في ريف حلب الجنوبي وصولا الى ريف
حماه الشماليه تلك المناطق تخضع لسيطره
النظام وميليشيات ايرانيه بقيت اياما
تعاني الماساه دون مساعده تذكر
ابرزها سراقب ابو الظهور والحاضر ومعره
النعمان يقول الاهالي ربما كان النظام
وميليشياته يقصدون تجاهلها بعد ان ظلت
عصيه لنحو سبعه اعوام لكن النظام عزا
الامر لضعف الامكانيات
ايضا قرى في عفرين وخاصه بلده جنديرس التي
تكتظ بمهجرين سوريين وتخضع لسيطره فصائل
المعارضه والجيش التركي لم يصلها احد
فتكفل الاهالي بدفن ضحاياهم الى جانب قرى
بريف جبله والقدموس بريف اللاذقيه تعرضت
للتجاهل ما اضطر قاطنيها الى التصرف
بامكانات محدوده
وتقول منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه ان معظم
القرى التي تم تجاهلها من قبل النظام
والمعارضه تعاني من الفقر وابسط مقومات
الحياه ناهيك عن البنايات التي شيدها
مقاولون وانهارت في اللحظات الاولى من
الزلزال بسبب الغش بمواد البناء
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام هزه ارضيه جديده سجلت
قبل حوالي عشر دقائق من الان المركز
الامور المتوسطي للزلازل يقول ان هذه
الهزه
مركزها وسط تركيا وبلغت شدتها
4.7 درجات على مقياس ريختر
هذه الهزه في وسط تركيا شعره بها السكان
في عديد المحافظات السوريه وكذلك في بعض
المناطق اللبنانيه قبل قليل اذا معنا الان
مباشره من ريف ادلب صحفي محمد الاشقر محمد
بدايه اي تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه الهزه
الجديده وهل شعرتم بها هناك في ريف ادلب
نعم يعني في الحقيقه نحن هنا دعني اسف لك
المشهد هنا قبل قليل في تمام الساعه
العاشره و 48 دقيقه بالضبط بتوقيت دمشق
عندما حدثت هذه الهزه الارتداديه طبعا
حاله من الهلع والخوف يعني اصابت هذا
المكان الجميع يعني ركض الى خارج بناء
المشفى يعني خوفا من ان هذه الهزه قد تكون
زلزال المدنيون الموجودون هنا في المشفى
كان السؤال هنا يعني ما هي احتماليه ان
يضرب زلزال جديد مشابه للسابق المنطقه من
جديد طبعا بحسب ما وصلنا قبل قليل ان هناك
العديد من العائلات يعني تركت بيوتها خوفا
من حدوث هزات ارتداديه
مشابهه لهذه الهزه الى الرعب
مرتبطا باي اهتزاز بالنظر الى الهزه
او زلزلان قويان اللذان ضرب قبل 11 يوما
تركيا وسوريا اذا ما نعلمه حتى الان انه
هي درجه يعني الزلزال درجته 4.7 على مقياس
مركزه وسط تركيا وشعر به السكان في
محافظات سوريا عده وكذلك في لبنان شعر به
الناس هناك ايضا اذا كما تفضلت محمد بعد
هذه الهزه الناس هربوا من المستشفى مستشفى
الامل الذي يعني يعني تطلعنا على وضعيته
هناك هل الان عاد
غالبيه الطاقم وكذلك مكانه موجودين في
المستشفى وحدثني كذلك عن الوضع الصحي في
هذا المستشفى والخدمات التي تقدم
نعم يعني في الحقيقه يعني تحيه للطاقم
الطبي الموجود هنا الذي عمل على
تهدئه الاهالي من الذين خرجوا الى خارج
هذا المشفى
واعادتهم الى ذويهم في الطابق السفلي طبعا
نحن هنا في الطابق الثاني من هذا المشفى
حفاظا على خصوصيات بعض المرضى الذين رفضوا
الظهور امام الكاميرا لاسباب خاصه طبعا
تحدثت قليلا عن الوضع الصحي في عموم منطقه
شمال غرب سوريا فنحن نحذر من كارثه طبعا
انسانيه قد تصيب هذه المنطقه نتيجه
احتماليه انتشار اوبئه بحسب ما وصف
الاطباء والناشطون الاغاثيون الذين اطلقوا
نداءات استغاثه
لتسريع وتكثيف المساعدات الطبيه التي تدخل
الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا طبعا دعني ان ان
استغل الوقت المتاح لي بان استضيف معي
الطبيب نهاد عبد المجيد
ليحدثنا اكثر بتفاصيل بتفاصيل اكثر عن
الوضع الصحي في عموم مشى في شمال غرب
سوريا اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور بدايه لو
حدثتنا القدره الاستيعابيه للمشافي
المشافي مقتظه بالمصابين والمرضى
كيف تعاملتم مع هذا الموضوع حياكم الله
اهلا وسهلا شكرا لكم اخي على هذه
الاستضافه في الحقيقه نحن في مشفى الامل
التخصصي للجراحه العظمي في منطقه سلقين
وحارم منذ ساعات الاولى ووفد الينا ما
يقارب اكثر من الف اصابي ولا تم وتم في
المرحله الاولى اجراء الفرز تمت اجراء
العمليات الاسعافيه ما يزيد عن 100 حالي
وتم نقل الحالات التي تحتاج الى اختصاصات
اخرى الى مشافي مثل ادلب وباب الهوى
طيب تحدثنا قليلا بالارقام القدره
الاستيعابيه لمشفى الامل التخصصي كمثال
قلت ان الف مصاب وصل الى هذا المشفى ما هي
القدره الاستيعابيه لمشفى الامل وكيف
تعاملتم مع هذا العدد حقيقه القدره
الاستيعابيه لمشفى الامل وجميع مشافي في
المنطقه في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
لا تستطيع استيعاب الحالات الكبيره التي
اجت في المشفى الامل تقريبا عدد الاسير ما
يقارب حوالي 60 سريع قلت لك ان اكثر من
الف اصابه تم اجراء الفرز
وتقدير الحالات ثم ارسالهم الى البيت
واعادتهم في الايام القليله لاستكمال
الاجراءات الجراحي نعم طيب الاصابات التي
وصلت اليكم ما هي اكثر
الاختصاصات التي تم العمل عليها يعني
الطواقم الطبيه المختصه بهذه اختصاصات
يقال انهم عملوا لايام طويله كيف تعاملتم
ايضا مع هذا الموضوع الحقيقه اكثر
التخصصات الطبيه التي عملت في الاصابات
التي اتت من الزلازل هي الجراحه العظمي
الجراحه الواعي كان حالات هناك بتور اطراف
الاذيات الهرسي تم اجراء حجرات بشكل
اسعافي ومن ثم تم تحويلهم الى مشافي
داخليه لمتابعه حاله الكلي والجسم بشكل
عام طيب انت حدثنا قليلا عن المساعدات
الطبيه التي وصلت الى المنطقه هل هي تكفي
المشافي الحقيقه مثل ما معلوم منطقه شمال
غرب سوريا هي منطقه حرب ما يزيد عن عشر
سنوات بالاصل الامكانيات الطبيه بتكون
كانت ضعيفه ولا تزال
وزادت المشكله اثر الزلزال الذي حدث او
الحقيقه ما زالت المساعدات الطبيه خجولي
وظائفي ونحن نامل ان تصل كلمتنا الى الدول
العالم لارسال المزيد من الادويه والمعدات
حتى الطبيه المتطوره كاجهزه الطبقه
المحوري والتصوير الشعاعي واجهزه غسيل
الكلى
دكتور نهاد طبعا نعم طبعا شكرا لك ولكن
اريد ان استغل وجودك معي يا محمد لو تكرمت
لمتابعه يعني يعني ما بعد هذه الهزه
الجديده التي
شعرتم بها هناك في شمال سوريا ومركزها وسط
تركيا اذا بالامكان ان تاخذنا في جوله معك
في المستشفى
مستشفى الامل التخصصي لكي نتابع معك
قليلا الاجواء ما بعد هذه الهزه
الارتداديه الجديده كما ذكرت شدتها 4.7
درجات
نعم يعني في الحقيقه دعني ان اعتذر منك
ومن المشاهدين لا يمكننا التجول بالكاميرا
بسبب تجهيزاتنا السلكيه يعني الامر حاليا
لا نستطيع التجوال داخل المشفى ولكن هل
هذه الهزه يعني كانت يعني كيف يمكن ان تصف
قوتها وهل تسببت يعني غير الرعب الذي
وصفته لنا قبل قليل وهروب الناس من
المستشفى هل هناك اي نوع من انواع الاضرار
نعم يعني دعني احدثك عن المشهد هنا في
المشفى يعني عندما حدثت الهزه جميع
الابواب بدات بالاهتزاز الاصوات التي صدرت
عن هذه الابواب هي التي تسببت بالدرجه
الاولى بحاله الهلع والخوف ولكن بحسب ما
وردنا من انباء من مختلف المناطق مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا فان هناك العديد من
الاهالي الذين تركوا منازلهم بعد هذه
الهزه خوفا من حدوث هزات مشابهه خصوصا
اننا نتحدث عن منطقه تضررت بشكل كبير
وهناك عدد كبير من المباني التي تصدعت
يعني
الى حد هذه اللحظه لا يوجد احد قيم
الابنيه
يعني وفرزها بحسب قدرتها على الصمود امام
مثل هذه الهزات يعني خصوصا ان الهزه
السابقه شعرت بها اغلب سكان المناطق شمال
غرب سوريا وكانت قويه درجه كبيره نعم طيب
اذا مازلنا معك محمد لان هذا التطور
بالفعل اعاد الى الاذهان الهزه القويه
الهزتان القويتين طبعا قبل 11 يوما
وما تلاها كذلك من هزات ارتداديه بالمئات
من الهزات الارتداديه بعد ذلك بالمقارنه
مع هزه اليوم هزت هذا المساء هذه الهزه
الارضيه
منذ متى لم تسجل اي هزه ارتداديه محمد
نعم يعني في الحقيقه لم تتوقف الهزات
الارتداديه منذ بدايه هذه الكارثه حتى
اللحظه طبعا تتكرر الهزات الارتداديه مع
اختلاف شدتها وقوتها يعني الهزه
الارتداديه الاخيره يعني لو طالت قليلا
لربما قد تسببت بكارثه جديده هنا نتيجه
قوتها الكبيره يعني ويعني الذي ساهم بعدم
الى حد هذه اللحظه يعني حقيقه يعني حدثت
الهزه قبل خروجنا معكم في هذا البشس
المباشر ولم يتسنى الى حد هذه اللحظه
الوصول الى اي انباء جديده من خلال
التواصل مع باقي الزملاء في باقي المناطق
ولكن ما وصلنا هو ان العديد من العائلات
هربت خوفا من تكرار الكارثه التي حلت يعني
حاله الهلع التي اصابت الاهالي هي نتيجه
اوه من هول الكارثه السابقه طبعا ان
سالتني عن الفرق ما بين الهزه او الزلزال
لحظه حدوث الزلزال وهذه الهزه فهناك فرق
كبير عندما حدثت هذه الكارثه يعني لا يمكن
وصف المشهد الذي
حدث هنا في في شمال غرب سوريا يعني دعني
ان اتحدث لك عن عن نفسي وانا احد سكان هذه
المنطقه يعني هرعت الى اولادي خوفا عليهم
ولم اعرف ما اتصرف
لحمايتهم والعديد هنا من السكان واهالي
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا يعني
لا زالوا يعانون من حاله الخوف والهلع
هناك العديد من الاطفال يرفضون العيش في
المنازل نتيجه ما راوه من هول الكارثه
عندما حدثت فما بالك وهناك هزه جديده تضرب
مره اخرى فهي مباشره الانسان يستشعر طبعا
حاله
هذه طيب محمد هذه الهزه الجديده اذا يتم
تسجيلها وطبعا
هذه المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال ما زالت
فيها مباني متهالكه او ايله للسقوط هلا
حدثنا كذلك على
نسبه المباني المدمره او التي تضررت بشكل
كبير عندكم في ريف ادلب
وكذلك اعمال رفع الركام اذا كانت بدات او
لا
نعم يعني في الحقيقه اكثر يعني المناطق
المتضرره من هذا الزلزال هي يعني
بالاغلبيه المناطق المحاذيه للحدود
السوريه التركيه لعل اكبرها في ريف ادلب
هي مدن حارم وسلقين وقريه بسنيا
وعزمارين وارمناز ومن ليس طبعا في هذه
المدن التي حدثت بها الكارثه الكبرى هناك
العديد من المنازل المتصدعه طبعا مدينه
جنديرس في ريف حلب ايضا هناك العديد من
المنازل المتصدعه مدينه جنديرس اكثر من
80% من منازلها اما دمرت بشكل كامل وسويت
في الارض او ان او انها دمرت بشكل جزئي
والعشرين في المئه التي بقيت سالمه هي
متصدعه ولو بنسبه قليله طبعا بالنسبه
لعمليات ازاله الركام فنحن نتحدث هنا عن
عمليه بالبدايه عن عمليه انت الضحايا من
تحت الانقراض التي توقفت نسبيا يعني
فرق الدفاع المدني لا تزال منتشره في بعض
المناطق التي تم مسحها وانتشال الضحايا
منها بغيت احتماليه ورود انباء حول وجود
ضحايا تحت انقاض مبنى ماء يعني هناك
العديد من المفقودين ذويهم يبحثون عنهم في
المشافي والنقاط الطبيه الميدانيه وحتى
مراكز الايواء المنتشره نتيجه حجم هذه
الكارثه هناك العديد من الاهالي الى حد
هذه اللحظه يبحثون عن ذويها وبحكم عملنا
كصحفيين هنا الكثير من الرسائل تريدنا حول
اسئله عن منطقه معينه من مناطق من عموم
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا التي اصابها الزلزال
سواء في ريف ادلب او ريف حلب الشمالي طيب
محمد سادعك تجمع المزيد من المعطيات حول
هذه الهزه الاخيره
التي تم تسجيلها قبل قليل ونبقى في على
تواصل معك اذا طوال هذه الليله لمتابعه
اذن
يعني ربما اثار هذه الهزه الجديده اذا
معنا الان الدكتور بدوي
رهبان المتخصص في الزلازل والكوارث دكتور
اهلا بك معنا هز جديده قبل قليل مركزها
وسط تركيا شدتها 4.7 درجات على مقياس
سنختار شعرت بها عديد المناطق والمحافظات
السوريه وكذلك حتى بعض المناطق في لبنان
هل تصنف هذه من الهزات الارتداديه للزلزال
الاول ام هذه هزه جديده
انها تصنف كهزا ارتداديه
لسبب بسيط هو ان مركزها مركزها هو في
منطقه الزلزال الرئيسي الذي حصل منذ عشره
ايام
وشهدنا ايضا اليوم الساعه ظهرا الساعه 11
تقريبا 30 دقيقه بتوقيت جرينتش يعني يعني
بتوقيت
شرق الاوسط تقريبا يعني الساعه 1:30 بعد
الظهر اليوم صارت كمان صارت كمان حدثت هزه
ارتداديه ايضا كانت درجتها
4.6 او سبعه وهلا وهلا الان من من نصف
ساعه
حصل هزي ارتداديه مثل ما حضرتك تفضلت
بذكره درجتها درجتها تقريبا خمسه على يسري
ومركزها ايضا ومركزها ايضا هو
المنطقه التي حدث فيها
الزلزال الرئيسي منذ تسعه ايام الدكتور
بدوي يعني بالعاده علميا يعني الهزه
الارتداديه يعني هل يمكن ان تصل الى نفس
شده درجه الزلزال الاول لانه الناس خائفون
بشكل كبير جدا الذين عايشوا الزلزال يعني
اي هزه
تعيدهم الى لحظه الزلزال المدمر علميا هل
يمكن ان نشهد زلزالا قويا اخر من ضمن هذه
الهزات الارتداديه
نعم ان علم الزلازل له مئات السنين يعني
وعشرات العقود نعرف نعرف عفوا بشكل عام
بشكل عام وباغلب الاحوال وباغلب الزلازل
التي حدثت والتي كان هناك مقياس لها نعرف
نعرف ان الهزات الارتداديه بشكل عام واشدد
بشكل عام
تخف وتيرتها بعد الزلزال الرئيسي وتخف
شدتها وهذا ما نشهده هذا ما نشهده منذ
تسعه ايام يعني الهزات الارتداديه وان شعر
بها الناس نشعر منذ تسعه ايام ان شدتها
تتضاءل وان وتيرتها تتضاءل اذا هذا يطابق
انه هذا ما لم افهمه يعني انه كما تفضلت
الهزاف الابتداديه يعني هي تاتي في شدات
متناقصه عن الزلزال الاول ولكن الهزه التي
ضربت قبل قليل يعني كما تفضلت هي تقريبا
خمسه
درجات على مقياس ريختر فكيف يفسر هذا ايضا
يعني هي اعلى من الهزات الارتداديه
السابقه نعم انا لم اكن لك انا لم اكن لك
ان الهزات الارتداديه على طول سوف تخف
يعني كل يوم
انا انا
قلت لك ان المنح منحى هو للتضاؤل وهذا لا
هذا لا يعني ربما لا يمكن ان نستغرب انه
ربما غدا او بعد غد او بعد ثلاث ايام تكون
الهزه الارتداديه ليس فقط خمسه ولكن ربما
تكون 5.2
ممكن تكون اعلى يعني بشدتها
يعني مثل يعني مثل مثل مثل اسنان المنشار
يعني عرفت كيف ولكن المنحه ولكن المنحه
المنحه يكون بشكل عام نحو التداول تدريجيا
تدريجيا طيب الى متى دكتور بدوي الى متى
يعني سنبقى نعيش حاله الرعب هذه من هذه
الهزات الارتداديه
تبقى بعد الزلزال تضرب فيها هزات ارتداديه
من الطبيعي ان يكون هناك قلق هذا
شيء ان كان في اليابان او في الولايات
المتحده او في تشيلي من الطبيعي ان يكون
عند الناس هذا الشعور يعني عندما نشعر بها
وايضا اريد ان اوضح مساله انك حتى اذا ما
شعرت حتى اذا ما كانت هذا الابتداديه
درجتها 4.8 ربما بعد السكان مثلا في لبنان
يشعرون فيها بها كانها درجه خمسه او ربما
في قبرص يشعرون بها كانها يعني يعني
الدرجه لا تعني الشعور الانساني في الهزه
يعني ربما يشعر فيها الانسان مثلا في
مدينه صور او في مدينه القاهره اكثر من من
ما يشعره شخص في سوريا او او في او في
الاردن
هذا هذا يتعلق بما نسميه الانسان سيتي
التي هي غير الدرجه مقياس ريشتر ولكن ولكن
المن
[موسيقى]
وهذه الصدوع تختلف بعضها عن بعض وليس حتى
هذه الساعه يعني انا لم ليس عندي الان
نماذج ليس عندي نماذج وليس عندي معطيات
يعني ولكن من المستتعد جدا من المستبعد من
المستحيل ان يكون هناك علاقه بين زلزال
تركيا وسوريا
اقل من 30 ثانيه وقت انتهى يعني ما هي
النصائح التي توجهها للسكان خاصه في تركيا
وفي سوريا ولبنان الان مع فتره الهزات
الارتداديه التي يمكن ان تحدث ما هي
النصائح التي يمكن ان نقدمها للمشاهدين
هناك
التي هي تعرف بالامور وان يتابعوا ما
يقولوا لهم الخبراء المختصين بهذه الامور
يعني نحن نشعر ان هناك نوع من القلق وهذا
طبيعي ولكن ان العلم الزلزالي يعني ليس
دقيقا مئه بالمئه ولكن اعطيتك انا كل ما
يكون عندي من خلاصه يعني لو انا لست الان
هناك في المنطقه انا في باريس ولكن اعطيتك
ما كنت اعطيه لو كنت ساكنا ايضا علميا
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور بدوي رهبان انت
المختص في شؤون المناخ والزلازل والكوارث
كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
وبعد مرور 11 يوما على وقوع الزلزال تبدو
فرص العثور على ناجحه تحت الانقاض مستحيله
غير ان هناك قصص نجاه اشبه بالمعجزات ان
بعثت من تحت الركام فبعد مرور
248 ساعه على وقوع الزلزال تمكنت فرق
لانقاذ التركيه من اخراج فتاه تبلغ من
العمر 17 عاما من تحت انقاض مبنى انهار في
اقليم كرمان مراش بجنوب وسط تركيا
[موسيقى]
وقبل قليل مشاهدينا انتشرت فرق لانقاذ
التركيه امراه على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاض في مدينه كرمان مرعش ايضا بعد
مرور 258 ساعه على الزلزال
[تصفيق]
عمليا تبدو حظوظ العثور على احياء تحت
الانقاذ ضعيفه للغايه بعد اليوم السابع من
وقوع اي زلزال لكن هناك قصصا لناجينا
صمدوا لمده اطول فماذا يقول العلم بهذا
الخصوص عوامل مختلفه مشاهدينا تؤثر على
مده بقاء الانسان على قيد الحياه اولها
موقع الانسان عند حدوث الانهيار فالحمايه
الجسديه تحت الحطام قد تساعد على الوصول
الى الهواء ولا شك ان توفر الماء مهم
للغايه للانسان فهو قد يعيش بدون ماء لمده
تتراوح بين ثلاثه وسبعه ايام فقط كما ان
مستوى الاصابات مؤثر للغايه لان فقدان
الدم يقلل من احتمال البقاء على قيد
الحياه اكثر من 24 ساعه ومن العوامل
الهامه التي غالبا ما يتم التقليل من
شانها هي الثبات النفسي والتحكم العقلي
والذي قد يكون امرا حاسما للبقاء على قيد
الحياه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بوتين يتعهد
بتقديم الدعم الاجتماعي لاعضاء فاجنر
الذين يقاتلون في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان اجتماعا مع مفوضه حقوق
الطفل في روسيا ماريا البوفا بلوفا ان
السلطات الروسيه تدرس مساله الضمانات
الاجتماعيه للمتطوعين في اشاره الى مقاتلي
فاجنر وهي نفس الضمانات الاجتماعيه التي
يتمتع بها العسكريون واضاف بوتين ان الذين
انضموا كجزء من التعبئه الجزئيه يقومون
بواجبهم تجاه وطنهم وفق تعبيره مشيرا الى
ان الجميع متساوون من حيث الضمانات
وجميع تدابير الحمايه الاجتماعيه
الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراع الدائر هناك
بين موسكو واكييف منذ ازيد من سنه رافقه
بروز شخصيات عديده احتلت المشهد السياسي
والاعلامي بشكل كبير فمن الجانب الروسي
طفت على السطح اسماء باتت ارقاما مهمه في
معادله الحرب شخصيه يطلق عليها اسم الصقور
قياسا بتاثيرها الكبير على مجريات الحرب
سواء عسكريا او اعلاميا ومن بين اكثر
الاسماء التي تم تداولها في الاونه
الاخيره والتي لعبت دورا هاما في المعارك
الميدانيه هو يفين
زعيم مجموعه
من دون منازع احد اشهر وجوه الحرب في
الوقت الراهن بل اصبح بمثابه قائد حربي
ولقب بامير الحرب حيث قاد مجموعه من
المعارك في اوكرانيا
ابرزها في محموك وتكفل هو شخصيا بتاسيس
مجموعه فاجنر سنه 2014 من خلال استقطاب
العديد من المحاربين والتجنيد الاف
السجناء
مشاهدينا باتا يظهر بشكل متكرر من خلال
العديد من المقاطع المصوره كما يتكفل
بنفسه احيانا بالاعلان عن تطورات المعارك
وشخصيه اخرى لعبت دورا هاما في هذا الصراع
من خلال التعبير بشكل مباشر عن مواقف
موسكو وخططها الحديث هنا هو عن الرئيس
الروسي السابق لمدفادر والذي تحول من
شخصيه ليبراليه الى احد اكبر مؤيدي
الاسلوب المتشدد في الحكم في روسيا
لا يمر اسبوع من دون ان ينشر رسائل
اللاذعه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولعل
ابرز رسائل وجهها هي التهديد المتكرر
بامكانيه استخدام روسيا للسلاح النووي
اما على المستوى الاعلامي فان الاسم
الابرز كان من دون شك هو رئيس تحرير شبكه
رشا توداي التلفزيونيه
هذه السيده كانت مسؤوله بشكل كبير عن
الجانب الدعائي من الحرب وتظهر سيمونيا
بانتظام في البرامج التلفزيونيه حيث تلقي
خطابات لتحفيز مواطنيها او تهديد الخصوم
طالت سيمونيانا العقوبات الغربيه بشكل
مباشر مع حظر فروع شبكه ار تي التلفزيونيه
في معظم الدول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان امريكا
ستسقط اي جسم طائر يمثل تهديدا لها وقال
بايضا انه لن يعتذر للصين على اسقاطي
منطاضها مشيرا الى انه سيواصل تنافس مع
الصين وحول الاجسام الغريبه الاخرى التي
تم رصدها في المجال الجوي الامريكي قال
بايدن ان بلاده لا تعرف بالضبط ماهيه هذه
الاجسام الا ان الاستخبارات ترجح انها
كانت تابعه لشركات خاصه او مؤسسات بحثيه
[موسيقى]
تصعيد جديد في ازمه المصارف في لبنان
فالوضع يزداد تفاقما اسبوعا بعد اخر في
اخر التطورات قام عملاء غاضبون غير قادرين
على سحب مدخراتهم بتحطيم واجهات عدد من
البنوك اللبنانيه في العاصمه بيروت كما
اضرموا النار في بعضها احتجاجا على فرض
قيود على سحب اموالهم الحركات الاحتجاجيه
هذه سبقتها تظاهرات حاسده في الشوارع ضد
القيود المفروضه على السحب النقدي مما ادى
الى اغلاق بعض الطرق هذا واعلن وزير
الاقتصاد اللبنانيه من سلام ان حكومه
تصريف الاعمال قررت السماح بتسعير السلع
بالدولار
معنا من بيروت صحفيه المختصه بشان
الاقتصاديه محاسن مرسل استاذه محاسن اهلا
بكى معنا في اخبار الساعه يعني الدولار
يستخدم يعني شعبيا بشكل كبير في لبنان منذ
وقت طويل ولكن رسميا ان يتم تسعير السلع
بالدولار ماذا يعني هذا
مساء الخير
يوم في لبنان كان هنالك دوله مصرفيه اي ان
النسبه الاعلى من الودائع هي ودائع
بالدولار الامريكي هذه الخطوه قام بها
حاكم مصرف لبنان بعد الحرب الاهليه
اللبنانيه وساهمت طبعا كان هنالك استقرار
بسعر صرف ليره او ثبات بسعر صرف الليره
على 1500 ليره لبنانيه وللاسف مع انطلاق
ازمه عام 2019 الازمه الاقتصاديه والماليه
والنقديه ان انتقلنا الى الكاش ايكونومي
او الاقتصاد النقدي والقائم يعني في شبه
معطل دور المصارف في لبنان كل الناس تلجا
الى التعامل بالناقد واليوم يعني عزز هذا
الامر باعلان للاسف الجهات الرسميه
اللبنانيه بدوره السلع طبعا هذه الخطوه
الثانيه من بعد اعلان دوله القطاع السياحي
في لبنان من فنادق ومطاعم هذه الحكومه
تلجا الى الحلول الترقيعيه خاصه ان الليره
اللبنانيه في لبنان فقدت قرابه 97% من
قيمتها
يمكن المشكله الاكبر اليوم ان تلجا سلطه
رسميه الى اعلان الدوله رافي حين ان معظم
المقيمين في لبنان يتقاضون رواتبهم
بالليره اللبنانيه
هل ستساهم قليلا في يعني الحفاظ على قيمه
الليره اللبنانيه التي كما ذكرتي يعني
فقدت اكثر من 95% من قيمتها
بالعكس يعني اليوم كانه السلطه اللبنانيه
عم بتقول انه الليره اللبنانيه فقدت
الحاجه الاساسيه لها او الدور الاساسي لها
المتعلق بالمبادلات
المبادلات الاقتصاديه وايضا بموضوع
المبادلات الاقتصاديه بجميع يعني
بكل المعاملات بيتم استخدام الليره
اللبنانيه اضافه الى موضوع الدولار اضافه
الى وحده قياس لليره اللبنانيه للاسف
الطريق الى الدوله يؤدي الى فقدان الثقه
بالليره اللبنانيه والى صعوبه استعاده
الثقه بالليره في المستقبل حتى لو كان
هنالك خطط اقتصاديه تصحيحيه شكرا جزيلا لك
ولكن محاسن قبل ان تغادرين اريد ان نستغل
وجودك معنا هل شعرت بالهزه الارضيه قبل
قليل
[موسيقى]
نعود الى متابعه خبر الساعه هذه الليله
الهزه الارضيه الجديده التي تم تسجيلها
قبل قليل هي هزه ارتداديه مركزها وسط
تركيا بلغت شدتها 4.7 درجات على مقياس
وشعرت بها بعض المحافظات السوريه خاصه في
الشمال السوري وبعض المناطق كذلك في لبنان
قبل قليل كان هناك خبر عن انهيار مبنى في
ريف حلب جراء الهزه الارتداديه هذه مع
وجود عالقين تحت الارقام حول هذا الموضوع
معنا من ريف حلب الشمالي الصحفي مسلم
السيد عيسى مسلم ما حقيقه
انهيار المبنى في في حلب بعد هذه الهزه
الجديده قبل قليل
في الحقيقه كان كانت الاجواء مرعبه جدا
هنا في سواء محافظه ادلب او حلب في شمال
السوري يعني بدات الاهالي كلها بالنزول
الى الشوارع وحتى الان لم يخرج الاهالي
ويعود الى منازلهم واماكنهم التي خرجوا
منها بسبب الخوف الشديد الذي اصابه
المنطقه تقريبا هي الهزه الارتداديه
الاقوى بعد الزلزال الذي حصل قبل ايام
لم يثبت حتى اللحظه بحسب ارتفاع المدني
ايه وقوع لابنيه او سقوط ابنيه طابقيه سوى
بعض الاضرار الماديه في بعض المخيمات التي
هي
من شقق سكنيه كان هناك تهدين في بعض الشقق
لكن لم يسجل اي اصابات سواء في محافظتي
حلب
شمال سوريا لكن بصراحه الاهالي تعيش الان
يعني كل من كان امن يوم في بيته الان عاد
الى الشوارع ونزل الى الطرقات يعني من نسي
رعب الزلزال تذكره هذه الليله بشكل كبير
جدا طيب
مسلم انت وصفت هذه الهزه هذه الليله بانها
الهزه الارتداديه الاقوى منذ زلزال
الاثنين قبل 11 يوما المده هل كانت طويله
يعني في الحقيقه تقريبا كانت من 15 الى 20
ثانيه تقريبا لكن كانت قويه بالفعل يعني
كلنا شعرنا برعب وخوف شديد بدانا بالنزول
الى الطوابق الصوفيه لكنها كانت قد انتهت
تقريبا لكن هناك يعني ما شاهدته العوائل
حتى الان في الشوارع لم يخرج احد من
العوائل خصوصا من لديه اطفال ونساء وكبار
سن الاهالي قالت انها ستنام اليوم في
العرق في خرجت الى الاراضي الزراعيه
وغيرها يعني من جرب الهزه الاولى والزلزال
[موسيقى]
يعني الاماكن التي كانت فيها الابنيه فعلا
يعني مهدمه او مهدده بالوقوع وقع يعني في
بلده جنديرس وايضا في بلده حارم قبل قليل
في الهزه وقعت بعض الابنيه لكن هي المدينه
بشكل عام خاليه من السكان لا يوجد فيها
احد بسبب اخلائها بشكل كامل في الاماكن
البعيده نوعا ما هناك اضرار فقط بسيطه لكن
العامل النفسي حقيقه اليوم الذي تعيشه
السكان هنا في المنطقه هو مرعب يعني الناس
بدات كل من نشاركه ونساله عن هذه الهزات
والزلزال الاساسي يقول انه بعد 11 يوم حتى
الان لا يزال يشعر برجفه في جسمه وبالتالي
الاهالي وخصوصا الاطفال وكبار السن في
المنطقه يعيشون حاله نفسيه نفسيه حقيقه
قاسيه تؤثر عليهم في حياتهم اليوميه نعم
مسلم شكرا جزيلا لك من ريف حلب الشمالي
ومشاهدينا كذلك وردنا للتو ان السكان في
جبله على الساحل السوري خرجوا الى الشوارع
خوفا من هذه الهزه الجديده كلوا ابقوا
دائما بخير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]